Salut,
c’est Romain,
de 1000 idées de culture générale.
J’ai deux petites choses importantes
à vous dire
avant que la vidéo ne commence.
PREMIÈRE CHOSE :
ne regardez PAS
la vidéo
comme ça,
avec du pop-corn.
Si vous voulez RETENIR
ce que vous allez apprendre
dans cette vidéo,
vous DEVEZ
prendre des notes.
Les études sur la mémorisation
ne laissent AUCUNE PLACE
au doute :
NE PAS PRENDRE
DE NOTES
ÉGALE
OUBLIER.
Donc faites-moi plaisir :
ouvrez une application
comme Google Docs
ou Evernote,
et NOTEZ
ce qui est essentiel pour vous
au fur et à mesure.
SECONDE CHOSE
que je dois vous dire :
la vidéo que vous allez regarder
est extraite de ma formation
de culture générale
qui s’appelle
« Culture Express ».
C’est une formation qui permet
d’acquérir RAPIDEMENT
une bonne culture générale,
SANS
se prendre la tête,
sans avoir à lire
ni à réfléchir.
Elle couvre tous les domaines
de la culture générale :
elle permet de maîtriser
les connaissances essentielles
sur l’histoire de l’humanité,
sur l’histoire de France,
en économie,
en science politique,
en psychologie,
en science,
en littérature,
en art,
en religion,
ET ENFIN...
...en philosophie
— eh oui,
c’est important
la philo.
Si ça vous intéresse,
jetez-y un coup d’œil,
soit en cliquant
sur le lien qui apparaît maintenant
en haut à droite de la vidéo,
soit en cliquant
sur celui qui est dans la description
de cette vidéo.
Voilà voilà,
je vous ai dit
ce que je voulais vous dire.
Maintenant
je vous laisse regarder la vidéo.
Concentrez-vous,
préparez-vous
à prendre des notes,
et puis n’hésitez pas à m’écrire
dans les commentaires.
Et moi je vous dis :
à la prochaine !
________________
Qu’est-ce que la science ?
« La science fait partie de la culture.
»
— Pierre Thuillier, Les Savoirs ventriloques
Je me souviens de la réaction de ma grand-mère
lorsque, il y a une dizaine d’années, je
lui ai dit que j’allais étudier la philosophie
à la Sorbonne en parallèle de ma scolarité
à en école de commerce : « Mais Romain,
ce n’est pas pour toi ! Tu es un matheux
! ». Sa réaction illustre un préjugé bien
ancré dans la société française : les
sciences et les lettres sont deux mondes distincts,
hermétiques — et peut-être même antinomiques.
Dès l'école, les enfants doivent choisir
entre scientifique et littéraire : la société
tout entière est sommée de choisir.
Cette distinction repose fondamentalement
sur l’idée que la science est un discours
sans appel, une forme supérieure de connaissance
dont la teneur en vérité la place au-dessus
des critiques et au-dessus de la culture — comme
autrefois la religion.
Impressionné par les prouesses techniques,
anesthésié par le confort, l’homme moderne
adhère à l’idée selon laquelle la science
est intouchable.
Or, les travaux des historiens montrent que
la science appartient malgré tout à la culture.
Elle n'est pas le pur discours de la vérité,
car elle s'inscrit dans une réalité à la
fois économique, politique et sociale.
Après, il faut reconnaître que la science
moderne produit des connaissances d’un niveau
de fiabilité inédit.
Mais on peut regretter le divorce entre la
science et la culture qui grandit depuis les
Lumières.
Les savants des XVIe et XVIIe siècles voyaient,
eux, le savoir comme un seul et vaste ensemble
dont l'homme cultivé doit pouvoir maîtriser
la totalité.
Dans cette leçon, je vais répondre aux questions
suivantes :
Comment définir la science ?
Quels sont les jalons de la conception de
la science ?
Comment la science progresse-t-elle ?
Comment classifier les sciences ?
Qui sont les scientifiques les plus importants
au XXIe siècle ?
Comment définir la science ?
Je vais tout d’abord vous expliquer comment
parvenir à une définition du mot « science
» dans son sens moderne.
Je vous présenterai ensuite les principaux
usages de ce mot (au singulier et au pluriel).
Enfin, j’évoquerai — sans aller dans
le détail — les méthodes de la science
ainsi que leur importance dans la définition
de la science.
Que signifie le mot « science » ?
Le nom commun « science » vient du verbe
latin scire, qui signifie « savoir ». Or,
savoir, c’est avoir une information présente
à l’esprit, en être instruit.
Par exemple, je sais que la température extérieure
est de -5°C.
Je n’y pense pas en permanence, mais cette
information se situe dans l’espace mental
de ma conscience ; elle est accessible comme
le dictionnaire posé à ma droite sur mon
bureau est accessible : en un petit mouvement
de l’esprit, je me rappelle l’information
comme en un petit mouvement du corps je saisis
le dictionnaire.
L’étymologie du mot « science » le lie
donc à l’idée de la possession de l’information.
Mais l’idée de la science recèle une autre
dimension essentielle.
Puis-je dire que je sais que la température
extérieure est de 25°C, quand elle est en
réalité de -5°C ? Non, cela n’a pas de
sens.
Cette information fausse (la température
extérieure est de 25°C) est absente de mon
esprit, comme toutes les autres informations
fausses (par exemple, la température extérieure
est de 50°C), parce qu’elle est inutile,
sinon nocive du point de vue de la vie.
En revanche, savoir que la température extérieure
est de -5°C est utile : je vais par exemple
me munir de mon bonnet, de mon écharpe et
de mes gants pour sortir mon chien.
Ainsi, l’idée de science implique aussi
que l’information que je possède soit vraie.
Mais comment définir la vérité ? Les philosophes
ont énormément réfléchi et écrit pour
répondre à cette question, donc je vais
me contenter d’une réponse simple et satisfaisante.
La vérité est la correspondance entre la
pensée et la réalité.
Si je pense à une chose, et que cette chose
existe — alors elle est vraie.
Par exemple, je pense que la température
extérieure est de -5°C, et c’est effectivement
le cas, donc l’information est vraie.
Mais si j’imagine que j’ai terminé d’écrire
le script de cette leçon, la réalité n’est
pas conforme à cette pensée à l’instant
où j’écris ces lignes — donc ce n’est
pas vrai, c’est un fantasme (mais il deviendra
la vérité dans une dizaine d’heures).
La définition de la science par la vérité
pose cependant un problème : comment être
certain que l’information que je possède
est bien vraie ? Il y a diverses manières
d’atteindre cette certitude, ou plutôt
de s’en rapprocher — mais la certitude
absolue est un idéal.
Par exemple, suis-je absolument certain que
la température extérieure est de -5°C ? Et
si le thermomètre est cassé (ce n’est
pas impossible du tout) ? Alors, pourquoi
considérer cette information comme vraie
? Parce que je pense que le thermomètre fonctionne.
À ma connaissance, il ne s’est jamais trompé
depuis que je l’utilise — donc je fais
le pari qu’il ne se trompe pas aujourd’hui.
Autrement dit, je lui fais confiance.
Cet exemple m’amène à l’idée qui me
paraît cruciale pour définir la science
: la fiabilité.
Voici la véritable propriété de ce que
nous savons, des informations qui relèvent
de la science : lorsqu’elles sont disponibles
dans notre esprit, nous leur faisons confiance.
La science se définit dans l’absolu par
rapport à la production de connaissances
fiables.
Dans le détail, elle est :
soit l’effort, le processus de la production
de connaissances fiables (c’est dans ce
sens qu’on parle du « progrès de la science)
;
soit les méthodes de production (c’est
dans ce sens qu’on dit par exemple que « la
science repose sur le doute ») ;
soit le résultat de l’effort de production,
c’est-à-dire l’ensemble des connaissances
fiables produites (c’est dans ce sens qu’on
dit « faire étalage de sa science ») ;
soit l’organisation des connaissances fiables
produites (c’est dans ce sens qu’on dit
par exemple que « la chimie est une science
»).
« La science est du savoir organisé.
»
— Herbert Spencer, Éducation
Si vous voulez une définition plus simple,
vous pouvez retenir que la science est une
forme de savoir particulier — distinct du
savoir philosophique, politique, religieux,
artistique, etc. — qui se caractérise par
un niveau de fiabilité supérieur.
Quels sont les principaux usages du mot « science
» ?
Ce mot a une longue histoire, c’est pourquoi
il existe aujourd’hui dans la langue française
de nombreux usages qui ne correspondent plus
forcément à la définition moderne.
Voici les principaux usages du mot « science
» :
Il est utilisé au singulier pour signifier
une compétence, une habileté spécifique.
Par exemple, une personne qui a « la science
du monde » est à l’aise et habile dans
les mondanités : elle en connaît les codes
et elle sait se rendre agréable dans la vie
sociale des élites.
Autre exemple, on peut dire que « la science
du cavalier consiste notamment dans l’accord
de la main et des jambes ».
La « science-fiction » est une expression
qui vient des États-Unis.
Elle désigne un sous-genre de la fiction
qui met à profit des hypothèses et des résultats
de la science de l’époque, voire une anticipation
des résultats futurs pour inventer un monde
qui frappe l’imagination.
Par exemple, Matrix est un film de science-fiction.
Les « sciences de la nature » (ou « sciences
naturelles ») sont les disciplines qui ont
pour objet le monde naturel, c’est-à-dire
le monde physique indépendant de l’action
humaine.
Par exemple, la zoologie, qui étudie les
animaux, ou encore la botanique, qui étudie
les végétaux, sont des sciences de la nature.
Les « sciences morales » sont les sciences
qui ont pour objet l’esprit humain et les
rapports sociaux.
Cette expression était surtout utilisée
au XIXe siècle dans le but de rassembler
toutes les sciences « non physiques », c’est-à-dire
qui ne portent pas sur la matière.
Par exemple, la philosophie, la psychologie,
le droit ou l’histoire sont des sciences
morales.
Mais l’expression elle est tombée en désuétude
au XXe siècle.
Les « sciences humaines » est l’expression
qui l’a remplacée.
Elle met davantage l’accent sur le fait
que les disciplines étudient les comportements,
individuels ou collectifs, directement observables
des hommes.
Attention : une science relative à l’homme
n’est pas forcément une science « humaine
» (par exemple, l’anatomie n’est pas
une science humaine).
Ainsi, une science humaine étudie ce qui
caractérise l’homme par rapport au reste
de la nature.
Les « sciences appliquées » sont les sciences
qui ont pour objet, comme leur nom l’indique,
d’appliquer à une fin pratique des connaissances
théoriques.
On parle par exemple de la physique appliquée
ou des mathématiques appliquées.
Louis Pasteur a critiqué cette expression
parce qu’elle suggère que l’application
des connaissances scientifiques est une activité
de technologie, et non plus de science.
Les « sciences occultes » sont les disciplines
qui produisent des connaissances dont la transmission
est orale (il n’y a pas d’archives) et
ésotérique (c’est-à-dire réservée à
une minorité d’initiés).
La magie, l’astrologie ou la divination
sont des sciences occultes.
La plupart s’évanouissent quand on les
soumet à la critique, mais il y a des exceptions,
comme l’hypnose.
Quelles sont les méthodes de la science ?
La science se définit fondamentalement par
l’exercice d’une méthode, car c’est
le moyen de garantir la fiabilité des connaissances
produites.
Issu du grec methodos, qui signifie « cheminement,
recherche », une méthode consiste précisément
en une suite d'opérations à accomplir pour
arriver à un résultat en évitant des errements.
Le Discours de la méthode de Descartes est
le livre emblématique de la définition de
la science par la méthode.
Pour illustrer l’importance de la méthode,
Descartes reprend la métaphore du chemin
de Sénèque (dans La vie heureuse) : réfléchir
sans méthode, c’est comme se précipiter
en changeant sans cesse de direction — on
ne risque pas d’arriver quelque part.
Rien ne sert donc d’aller vite si on n’est
pas sur le bon chemin.
Descartes prétend avoir trouvé :
« [...] la vraie méthode pour parvenir à
la connaissance de toutes les choses
dont (mon) esprit serait capable.
»
— René Descartes, Discours de la méthode
Il a élaboré cette méthode spéciale (dont
je vous parlerai dans la 4ème leçon) en
s’inspirant du raisonnement mathématique,
les mathématiques étant à ses yeux la science
la plus fiable.
Et il s’engage à en faire bon usage pour
progresser dans la vérité.
Ce que montre le propos de Descartes, c’est
que la science se caractérise tout d’abord
par une méthode de raisonnement.
En effet, la science demande de réfléchir
en suivant des règles qui permettent de passer
d’une proposition à une autre en étant
certain que si la proposition de départ est
vraie, alors la proposition d’arrivée l’est
aussi.
Par exemple, j’ai le droit de passer de
« Michael Jordan mesure 1,98 mètre » à
« Michael Jordan mesure moins de 2 mètres
» ; en revanche, je n’ai pas le droit de
faire l’inverse, de passer de « Michael
Jordan mesure moins de 2 mètres » à « Michael
Jordan mesure 1,98 mètre », parce que le
fait que quelqu’un mesure moins de 2 mètres
ne signifie pas forcément qu’il mesure
1,98 mètre (il pourrait mesure 1,80 mètre).
Les règles qui permettent de faire circuler
la vérité d’une proposition à la suivante
relèvent de la logique.
La logique est, au sens strict, la science
de la validité des opérations intellectuelles
(pour trouver la vérité).
La science se caractérise encore par les
méthodes qui permettent de faire circuler
la vérité entre les niveaux général et
particulier.
Une vérité générale décrit un ensemble
d’éléments ou bien pose une caractéristique
commune aux éléments d’un ensemble.
Par exemple, « les joueurs de l’équipe
mesurent plus d’1,90 mètres » est une
vérité générale.
En revanche, « Michael Jordan mesure 1,98
mètre » est une vérité particulière parce
qu’elle concerne un élément (en l’occurrence
un individu) unique.
Pour comprendre la transmission de la vérité
entre le général et le particulier, il faut
s’intéresser à l’opposition classique
entre la déduction et l’induction :
La déduction (du latin deductio, « action
d’emmener ») est l’opération logique
par laquelle on passe d’une proposition
générale à une proposition précise qui
en est la conséquence nécessaire.
Par exemple, je connais la loi de la gravitation
universelle (théorisée par Newton au XVIIe
siècle) et j’en déduis que la pomme qui
est tombée de l’arbre sur ma tête a été
attirée par la Terre.
La méthode déductive permet par exemple
de faire des découvertes dans le monde physique
à partir de vérités générales de nature
mathématique.
L’induction (du latin inductio, « action
d’amener ») est l’opération mentale
qui consiste à remonter de propositions particulières
à des propositions plus générales.
Par exemple, je sais qu’à chaque fois que
je tiens un livre dans ma main, puis que j’ouvre
ma main, le livre tombe ; j’induis de ces
cas particuliers qu’une force attire naturellement
le livre vers le sol.
Le philosophe Karl Popper prétend néanmoins
que l’induction n’est pas une méthode
100 % fiable parce qu’il y a toujours le
risque que des cas particuliers inconnus invalident
la vérité générale.
Par exemple, je regarde la taille de la grande
majorité des joueurs de basket de la NBA,
et j’en induis qu’un joueur de ce championnat
mesure toujours plus d’1,90 mètre.
Or, il est possible que je n’ai pas remarqué
la minorité de joueurs de moins d’1,90
mètre — auquel cas la méthode de l’induction
m’a entraîné à poser une proposition
générale fausse.
Le scientifique recourt à la méthode inductive
lorsqu’il observe et/ou mène des expériences,
puis théorise des lois à partir des résultats.
L’opposition entre la déduction et l’induction
est à l’origine de 2 méthodes scientifiques
:
la méthode hypothético-déductive consiste
à formuler une hypothèse générale, puis
à en examiner la validité en étudiant les
vérités particulières qui doivent découler
de l’hypothèse générale ;
la méthode empirico-inductive consiste à
partir de vérités particulières (des faits,
des données observables) pour remonter vers
une hypothèse générale susceptible de les
expliquer.
Quels sont les jalons de la conception de
la science ?
Je vais tout d’abord vous parler des conceptions
de la science qui prévalent dans l’Antiquité.
J’évoquerai, dans un deuxième temps, la
conception de la science qui émerge à l’époque
moderne (à partir du XVIIe siècle).
Je vous expliquerai ensuite la conception
de la science qui s’impose au XIXe siècle,
le positivisme.
Enfin, je vous présenterai les conceptions
de la science les plus influentes à l’heure
actuelle.
Qu’est-ce que la science dans l’Antiquité
?
Dans l’Antiquité, la science n’est pas
un domaine séparé de l’intelligence humaine.
Elle est plus particulièrement soumise à
la philosophie, qui chapeaute et oriente toute
quête de la vérité.
Les « scientifiques » de l’Antiquité
sont tous également des philosophes.
Les conceptions essentielles sont celles des
2 géants de la pensée antique :
Platon emploie le terme « science » dans
plusieurs sens, mais dans sa classification
des degrés de la connaissance, il affirme
que la science est le degré le plus élevé.
Sa conception de la science est liée à sa
théorie des Idées : la véritable science
se caractérise par son objet, les Idées,
c’est-à-dire les modèles et essences éternelles
de la réalité.
Dans La République, il rapproche cette science
des mathématiques.
Comme les maths demandent de manipuler des
objets purement abstraits, elles entraînent
l’âme à s’élever vers la vérité.
Enfin, Platon définit aussi la science par
une méthode intellectuelle spéciale, la
seule qui permet d’atteindre l’essence
des choses, la dialectique.
Elle consiste essentiellement, en pratique,
à raisonner en reprenant les règles d’une
discussion rigoureuse, dont notamment la définition
des termes et le classement des idées.
Aristote a une vision de la science plus proche
de la nôtre.
Il admet une diversité de sciences, qui ne
sont pas toutes parfaites.
Il répète même qu’il ne faut pas exiger
de toutes les disciplines intellectuelles
le même degré d’exactitude.
« Il ne faut pas plus exiger une précision
égale dans toutes les œuvres de l'esprit,
qu'on ne l'exige pour les ouvrages de la main.
»
— Aristote, Éthique à Nicomaque
Dans le détail, il subdivise la science en
trois grands domaines : la science théorique
(les mathématiques, par exemple), la science
pratique, qui est tournée vers l’action
(la science politique, par exemple), et la
science productive qui, comme son nom l’indique,
sert à produire quelque chose (l’agriculture,
par exemple).
Sa conception de la science est bien moins
abstraite que celle de Platon (Aristote s’est
lui-même confronté au monde matériel pour
le comprendre).
Je vous explique dans la leçon suivante,
consacrée aux origines de la science, pourquoi
et comment la conception de la science d’Aristote
— plutôt que celle de son maître — a
été décisive dans le développement de
la tradition scientifique occidentale.
Qu’est-ce que la science moderne ?
Deux philosophes (et scientifiques) emblématiques
de l’époque moderne ont façonné la conception
de la science moderne :
L’Anglais Francis Bacon est le promoteur
de référence de l’empirisme (du grec empeiria,
« expérience »), c’est-à-dire de la
nécessité de fonder et de développer la
science à partir de l’observation de la
réalité, de l’expérience sensible.
Il défend cette thèse dans le Novum Organum.
Le Français René Descartes (que j’ai déjà
évoqué à propos de l’importance de la
méthode) est le promoteur de référence
du raisonnement scientifique.
Le progrès de la connaissance demande que
l’homme discipline sa pensée, qu’il l’astreigne
à une démarche rigoureuse comparable à
celle du raisonnement mathématique.
Descartes défend cette thèse dans son fameux
Discours de la méthode.
Je vous explique en détail ces deux visions
de la science dans la 4ème leçon du module,
consacrée à la naissance de la science moderne.
Qu’est-ce que le positivisme ?
Le mot « positivisme » vient du latin positivus,
qui signifie « qui repose sur quelque chose
; établi, conventionnel ». Cette étymologie
met en évidence l’idée d’une base solide
dont la fiabilité produise l’accord des
esprits.
Or, dans la conception positiviste de la science,
la fiabilité de la connaissance repose sur
le fait.
Mais qu’est-ce qu’un « fait » ? Issu
du verbe latin facere, « faire », le mot
« fait » désigne une chose qui existe ou
survient et dont la réalité est incontestable
— elle est évidente ou admise.
Ainsi, le positivisme pose que la science
équivaut à la connaissance des faits.
C’est de cette idée que découle une dimension
fondamentale de la science moderne : l’exigence
de la mesure.
En mesurant rigoureusement ce qu’il observe,
le scientifique alimente le progrès de la
connaissance en faits objectifs.
Cette démarche signifie plus fondamentalement
que la science n’a pas pour mission, comme
le prétend Platon, de découvrir l’essence
même de la réalité.
Elle doit se borner à identifier des lois,
c’est-à-dire des relations invariables
de succession et de similitude entre les phénomènes.
Cette conception de la science s’impose
aux XIXe et XXe siècles.
Son fondateur est le philosophe français
du XIXe siècle Auguste Comte (il présente
la conception positiviste de la science dans
son Cours de philosophie positive).
« Tous les bons esprits répètent depuis
Bacon qu'il n'y a de connaissances réelles
que celles qui reposent sur des faits observés.
»
— Auguste Comte, Cours de philosophie positive
Plus qu’une nouvelle thèse, le positivisme
apparaît comme une idéologie.
Il exprime en effet une confiance dans le
progrès scientifique qui aboutit à remplacer
Dieu par l’humanité armée de la science.
Désormais, la science suffit à guider les
actions des hommes.
Cette radicalisation du positivisme donne
ce qu’on appelle le « scientisme », l’attitude
qui consiste à croire que seule la science
est source de vérités et qu’elle a la
capacité de satisfaire tous les besoins de
l’intelligence humaine.
Bref, la science devient une religion.
À quelles conceptions la science du XXIe
siècle obéit-elle ?
Les deux principaux artisans de la formulation
des règles qui gouvernent le développement
de la science sont Claude Bernard, un médecin
français du XIXe siècle, et Karl Popper,
un philosophe autrichien du XXe siècle.
Voici leurs conceptions de la science :
Claude Bernard est le penseur de référence
de méthode expérimentale.
Il s’agit d’une démarche qui repose sur
le contrôle d’une hypothèse de départ
au moyen d’expériences répétées (d’où
l’adjectif « expérimentale ») qui permettent
d’étudier l’influence des paramètres.
Dans le détail, Claude Bernard distingue
deux postures : l’observateur se contente
de constater les phénomènes ; l’expérimentateur,
lui, raisonne à partir des données qu’il
a obtenues afin de provoquer de nouveaux phénomènes.
Cette distinction explique que l’approche
expérimentale ne se réduit pas à une simple
approche empirique.
Il s’agit plus précisément d’une méthode
hypothético-déductive que Claude Bernard
décompose en trois temps : la naissance d’un
sentiment à partir de l’observation stérile,
sans hypothèse de départ, de la nature ; l’application
de la raison pour produire une hypothèse
rationnelle ; et la vérification de l’hypothèse
par l’expérience.
Cette méthode élaborée pour empêcher le
dogmatisme est celle de la recherche médicale
moderne.
« Il faut modifier une théorie pour l’adapter
à la nature,
et non la nature pour l’adapter à la théorie.
»
— Claude Bernard, Introduction à l’étude
de la médecine expérimentale
Karl Popper fonde la science sur la « falsification
», qui signifie que le scientifique doit
chercher à prouver que son hypothèse est
fausse (plutôt que, selon la tendance naturelle
de l’esprit humain, de chercher à prouver
qu’il a raison).
Cette exigence découle du fait que la vérité
n’existe que sur un mode négatif et temporaire
: une chose est vraie tant qu’on n’a pas
montré qu’elle est fausse.
Le chercheur ne peut donc avoir de certitude
que sur ce qui est faux.
Cette conception de la vérité fonde une
méthode scientifique : poser une hypothèse
; puis la mettre à l’épreuve par des tests
reproductibles, de plus en plus précis, afin
de corriger l’hypothèse de départ par
essais et erreurs.
Ainsi, pour Popper, une théorie véritablement
scientifique ne peut pas être vérifiée
— elle doit toujours être réfutable (ou
falsifiable).
Il en conclut que les disciplines qui se prémunissent
contre la réfutation ne sont pas de véritables
sciences (c’est par exemple le cas de la
psychanalyse).
« L’irréfutabilité n’est pas vertu,
mais défaut.
»
— Karl Popper, Conjectures et réfutations
Comment la science progresse-t-elle ?
Je vais vous présenter les trois thèses
de référence sur le progrès de la connaissance
scientifique : celle selon laquelle la science
avance par une sorte de sélection naturelle
; celle selon laquelle elle avance par révolutions
successives ; et enfin celle selon laquelle
elle évolue en réalité de manière anarchique.
Y a-t-il une « sélection naturelle » des
idées scientifiques ?
En fondant la science sur la falsification,
Karl Popper développe une conception du progrès
de la connaissance qu’on peut qualifier
d’« évolutionniste » (en référence
à la théorie de l’évolution de Darwin).
De son point de vue, le processus d’accroissement
des connaissances dans l’espèce humaine
est comparable à l’émergence et au développement
des espèces vivantes à travers l’évolution
biologique.
Parmi les hypothèses et théories proposées
par les scientifiques, certaines survivront
aux autres parce qu’elles sont plus résistantes
aux tentatives de réfutation.
« Les progrès du savoir sont essentiellement
la transformation d'un savoir antérieur.
»
— Karl Popper, Des sources de la connaissance
et de l’ignorance
Seulement, comme pour une espèce animale,
la résistance d’une théorie scientifique
ne garantit pas sa pérennité.
Elle peut résister à la réfutation pendant
longtemps, puis finalement céder un jour.
Par exemple, le « géocentrisme » — la
théorie selon laquelle la Terre est au centre
de l’univers — a prédominé dans l’astronomie
occidentale de l’Antiquité jusqu’au XVIe
siècle, au cours duquel les contestations
en ont finalement eu raison : le géocentrisme
a perdu son crédit scientifique, et a été
remplacé par l’héliocentrisme, la théorie
selon laquelle c’est le soleil qui est au
centre de l’univers.
Ainsi, pour Popper, une théorie scientifique
est un discours organisé à propos d’une
partie de la réalité et qui demeure ouvert
à la confirmation ou à la mise en question.
Dans cette perspective, la connaissance scientifique
évolue dans un univers distinct de celui
des hommes de la communauté scientifique
qui la font et l’examinent.
Popper distingue plus précisément trois
univers : l’univers physique ; l’univers
de l’expérience psychologique subjective
(ce qu’il se passe dans l’esprit humain)
; et enfin l’univers des produits de la
création humaine, qui comprend la connaissance
scientifique.
La science progresse-t-elle par « révolutions
» ?
Thomas Kuhn affirme que la science progresse
grâce à des révolutions ponctuelles.
Dans La structure des révolutions scientifiques,
qui est LE livre de référence du XXe siècle
en histoire des sciences, il affirme que les
progrès de la science ne se résument pas
à une accumulation continue et linéaire
de connaissances, mais qu’ils se concrétisent
au contraire par des phénomènes sociaux
majeurs où une nouvelle vision du monde en
remplace une autre, considérée comme obsolète
du fait de son inefficacité scientifique.
Dans son activité « normale », la science
se caractérise par une unité de pensée
relativement stable autour d’un cadre théorique
consensuel.
C’est ce que Kuhn appelle un « paradigme
» : un ensemble de modèles acceptés comme
cadres de travail communs par les scientifiques.
Un paradigme scientifique se définit plus
précisément par quatre éléments principaux
: des principes métaphysiques généraux
qui orientent la vision du monde des scientifiques
; des hypothèses et des lois ; une méthodologie
qui délimite les comportements conformes
; et enfin, les outils permettant l’observation
scientifique.
Une fois un paradigme installé, l’activité
scientifique se résume essentiellement à
l’améliorer.
« C’est à des opérations de nettoyage
que se consacrent
la plupart des scientifiques durant toute
leur carrière.
»
— Thomas Kuhn, La structure des révolutions
scientifiques
Mais au bout d’un moment, les ajustements
du paradigme ne suffisent plus pour résoudre
les problèmes posés.
Les échecs amoindrissent la confiance de
la communauté scientifique dans le paradigme
et font émerger des efforts scientifiques
plus spéculatifs et éloignés du paradigme.
Par exemple, les échecs répétés de la
théorie de Ptolémée dans la détermination
de la position des planètes et des étoiles
ont entraîné l’émergence de la théorie
copernicienne, qui réussit, elle, en comparaison,
avec une précision inégalée.
Si la contestation du paradigme suscite une
résistance des scientifiques, en même temps
elle renouvelle leur vision du monde et leurs
outils.
La révolution scientifique introduit un nouveau
paradigme.
Elle n’est pas une rupture brutale et immédiate,
mais un processus progressif et graduel : elle
avance par les prises de position successives
des scientifiques confrontés à la crise
de leur paradigme.
Elle n’est véritablement achevée que lorsque
la communauté scientifique se rallie à une
nouvelle théorie consensuelle permettant
de dépasser le paradigme antérieur.
Par exemple, le passage, au XXe siècle, de
la physique de Newton à celle d’Einstein
est un véritable changement de vision du
monde, car l’espace et le temps n’ont
plus le même sens.
Le progrès de la science est-il anarchique
?
Un penseur a radicalement remis en cause la
vision traditionnelle de la science à la
fin des Trente Glorieuses.
Dans Contre la méthode, Paul Feyerabend affirme
que la science est loin d’être le discours
de rigueur, d’objectivité et de méthode
qu’elle prétend être.
À ses yeux, les épistémologues (c’est-à-dire
ceux qui étudient les principes et les méthodes
de la science) et les historiens de la science
plaquent leurs croyances — leur dogmatisme,
même — lorsqu’ils décrivent l’évolution
de la connaissance scientifique.
Reprenant l’histoire de la science, Feyerabend
estime qu’elle évolue essentiellement par
des coups de force : cette théorie s’appelle
l’« anarchisme épistémologique ». L'anarchie
et le désordre sont donc les véritables
facteurs du progrès scientifique : dans les
faits, les savants ne réussissent bien souvent
à produire du nouveau qu'en s’émancipant
des règles trop étroites de la recherche.
Le véritable génie scientifique est celui
qui ose bousculer les certitudes et les préjugés.
Il se sert de toutes les ressources à sa
disposition ; il n’hésite pas à tricher,
ou à aller chercher son inspiration dans
les domaines les plus surprenants.
Bref, l’image traditionnelle de la démarche
scientifique serait une illusion.
« La science est beaucoup plus proche du
mythe
qu'une philosophie scientifique n'est prête
à l'admettre.
»
— Paul Feyerabend, Contre la méthode
En définitive, la science ne serait que l'une
des nombreuses formes de pensée qui ont été
développées par l'homme — et même pas
forcément la meilleure.
Les scientifiques qui la considèrent comme
une forme supérieure de connaissance sont
des idéologues qui n’ont pas réfléchi
aux limites de leur mode de pensée.
Feyerabend plaide pour un développement libertaire
du savoir, hors de tout carcan méthodologique.
Comment classifier les sciences ?
Je vais tout d’abord vous expliquer la différence
entre, d’une part, les sciences dites « exactes
» (ou « dures », même si cet adjectif
est un anglicisme controversé parce qu’il
dévalorise les autres disciplines comme des
sciences « molles »), et d’autre part
les sciences dites « humaines ». Je vous
présenterai ensuite les sciences exactes
; puis les sciences humaines les plus importantes
dans la culture occidentale.
Quelle est la différence entre les sciences
exactes et les sciences humaines ?
La distinction entre les sciences exactes
et les sciences humaines est récente dans
l’histoire de la science occidentale : elle
date du XIXe siècle.
Comme je vous l’ai déjà dit, la science
au sens où nous l’entendons aujourd’hui
était autrefois intégrée dans l’ensemble
du savoir.
Pendant longtemps, le physicien est un « philosophe
de la nature » ; le scientifique était un
« savant » qui s’intéresse à diverses
formes de connaissances : il est souvent un
polymathe.
Ainsi, le mathématicien Pythagore fait de
la philosophie, théorise la politique, l’éducation,
et crée une secte ; Hippocrate, le « père
» de la médecine occidentale, est aussi
philosophe ; Aristote, qui passe pour le fondateur
de la biologie, veut tout savoir sur tout
; Léonard de Vinci, qui incarne la figure
du polymathe de la Renaissance, montre que
le scientifique peut également être un artiste
(Einstein dira que le scientifique doit être
un artiste) ; enfin, l’encyclopédiste des
Lumières — dont Diderot est peut-être
le meilleur exemple — est la dernière figure
du savant universel occidental.
Mais le progrès de la science impose une
nouvelle organisation du savoir :
d’un côté, les sciences « exactes », qui
comprennent dans un même ensemble les sciences
de la nature et les sciences formelles ;
de l’autre côté, les sciences humaines,
qui étudient les comportements, individuels
ou collectifs, directement observables des
hommes.
La thèse de référence qui explique cette
séparation est celle de Wilhelm Dilthey.
Il affirme que les sciences humaines forment
un champ spécifique du savoir parce que leur
objet ne se résume pas à la nature, mais
qu’il inclut également la subjectivité
humaine, c’est-à-dire la manière dont
l’homme donne un sens à son existence.
C’est la raison pour laquelle il les appelle
« sciences de l’esprit ». Il en déduit
que ces sciences ne peuvent pas travailler
avec les mêmes méthodes que les sciences
de la nature, et que les positivistes font
donc fausse route.
Dans sa perspective, la méthode des sciences
naturelles repose sur l’explication, au
sens où elles identifient l’enchaînement
objectif de causes qui produit un phénomène
naturel ; la méthode des sciences humaines,
quant à elle, repose sur la compréhension,
au sens où elles synthétisent des actes
ou des paroles sous un sens général.
« Une chute d’eau se compose de molécules
homogènes juxtaposées ;
mais une simple phrase, qui n’est pourtant
qu’un souffle sorti de notre bouche,
peut ébranler toute l’âme d’une société
et tout un continent.
»
— Wilhelm Dilthey, Introduction à l’étude
des sciences humaines
Quelles sont les principales sciences exactes
?
Je vais vous les présenter en fonction de
leur importance dans l’histoire de la science
occidentale.
Je vais distinguer, d’une part, les sciences
« formelles », qui étudient les objets
intellectuels ainsi que leurs relations ; et
d’autre part les sciences de la nature,
qui étudient le monde physique indépendant
de l’action humaine.
Il existe bien sûr des liens entre ces deux
types de sciences exactes (par exemple, les
mathématiques sont aujourd’hui indispensables
en physique).
Voici les principales sciences formelles :
Les mathématiques sont la science qui consiste
à mener des raisonnements sur des objets
abstraits comme les nombres, les figures,
ou encore les structures.
C’est l’idéal de la science exacte : depuis
le XXe siècle, les autres sciences exactes,
et même les sciences humaines, se mettent
à traiter mathématiquement leurs données
pour renforcer leur crédibilité scientifique.
La logique est la science de la validité
des opérations intellectuelles.
Elle faisait partie de la philosophie depuis
l’Antiquité (Aristote passe pour le fondateur
de la logique dans la pensée occidentale),
mais les mathématiques y ont été introduites,
comme dans d’autres disciplines, au XXe
siècle.
L’informatique est la science du traitement
rationnel et automatique de l’information
(l’ordinateur en est une application).
Le traitement repose sur l’algorithme, qui
est une suite finie et non ambiguë d’opérations
permettant d'atteindre un résultat.
Voici maintenant les principales sciences
de la nature :
L’astronomie (du grec astron, « astre », et
nomos, « loi ») est la science qui étudie
les corps célestes dans leur position, leur
mouvement et leur constitution.
C’est une des sciences les plus anciennes.
La médecine (du latin medeor, « soigner
») est la science qui étudie les moyens
de prévenir — même si cette dimension
est négligée — et de traiter les maladies.
Ma mère me répétait que la médecine « n’est
pas une science exacte » pour me dire que
le niveau de fiabilité du savoir médical
n’est pas le même que celui des sciences
emblématiques des sciences exactes, comme
les mathématiques ou la physique.
La physique (du grec phusis, « nature ») est
la science qui étudie les phénomènes de
la matière, de l’énergie, ainsi que leurs
interactions.
Elle passe pour la science la plus fiable
après les mathématiques.
La biologie (du grec bios, « vie », et logos,
« discours ») est la science qui traite
des phénomènes et des lois de la vie.
La chimie (du grec khumeia, « art de faire
fondre les métaux ») est la science qui
étudie les transformations de la matière.
Comme je vous l’expliquerai dans la 3ème
leçon du module, la chimie vient de l’alchimie.
La géologie (du grec ge, « terre », et
logos, « discours ») est la science qui
étudie l’écorce terrestre, sa formation,
la nature et la situation des roches et terrains
qui la composent.
Elle est née (dans sa forme moderne) au XVIIIe
siècle.
L’anthropologie (du grec anthropos, « humain
», et logos, « discours ») est la science
qui étudie les caractéristiques des populations
humaines.
Je la range parmi les sciences exactes parce
qu’elle produit des connaissances fiables
sur l’histoire de l’humanité, mais elle
est aussi une science humaine.
Quelles sont les principales sciences humaines
?
L’expression « sciences humaines » est
propre à la langue française (on dit plutôt
« social sciences » ou « humanities » en
anglais).
Le système éducatif français dit aussi
« sciences humaines et sociales » (SHS).
Je ne vais évoquer l’évolution de la catégorie,
car c’est un débat académique qui n’a
pas d’intérêt pour mieux comprendre le
monde.
Les sciences humaines (actuellement) les plus
importantes dans la culture occidentale sont
l’économie, l’histoire, la psychologie,
la sociologie, et la philosophie.
Formé à partir du latin socius, « uni,
mis en commun », et du grec logos, « discours
», la sociologie étudie les phénomènes
sociaux à partir de leurs propriétés propres.
Pour les définitions des autres sciences
humaines, je vous renvoie aux premières leçons
des modules correspondant.
On peut encore mentionner le droit, la science
politique, et la géographie parmi les sciences
humaines qui comptent dans la culture occidentale
au XXIe siècle.
Qui sont les scientifiques les plus importants
au XXIe siècle ?
Je vais vous présenter 5 scientifiques qui
comptent parmi les plus importants dans la
culture occidentale au début du XXIe siècle
: un physicien ; deux biologistes ; une anthropologue
; et un mathématicien.
J’ai essayé d’estimer l’influence culturelle
des plus grands scientifiques de notre époque
— mais il y a forcément une part de subjectivité
dans mon choix.
N’hésitez donc pas à me suggérer d’autres
noms dans les commentaires.
Que retenir de Stephen Hawking ?
Stephen Hawking est un physicien et cosmologiste
britannique mort en 2018.
Considéré comme un des plus brillants physiciens
depuis Einstein, il est sans doute le scientifique
le plus célèbre au début du XXIe siècle.
Sur le plan scientifique, il a contribué
à notre compréhension du Big Bang (l’explosion
à l’origine de l’univers qui se serait
produite il y a environ 14 milliards d’années,
et dont je vous parle dans la dernière leçon
du module) ; à celle des trous noirs et de
la relativité.
Il doit également sa notoriété au succès
de ses livres de vulgarisation.
Le premier qu’il a publié (en 1988), Une
brève histoire du temps, est immédiatement
devenu un best-seller.
Il y retrace les grandes théories de l’univers
depuis Galilée.
Il essaie aussi de relever le plus grand défi
de la science moderne : rendre compatibles
la théorie de la relativité (qui explique
l’infiniment grand) et la mécanique quantique
(qui explique l’infiniment petit).
Sur le plan personnel, Stephen Hawking est
un homme inspirant parce qu’il souffre depuis
sa vingtaine d'une maladie rare qui a dégénéré
jusqu’à le laisser presque complètement
paralysé.
Il vivait donc dans une chaise roulante équipée
d’un matériel informatique.
Ce handicap est raconté dans le film biographique
Une merveilleuse histoire du temps.
Que retenir de Francis Crick et James Watson
?
Francis Crick et James Watson forment un des
couples de chercheurs les plus célèbres
de la science moderne (pas « couple » au
sens romantique).
Ils ont découvert la structure en double
hélice de l'ADN en 1953, ce qui leur a valu
le Prix Nobel de médecine en 1962.
Francis Crick est un biologiste britannique
du XXe siècle (il est décédé en 2004).
Pour l’anecdote, son nom est associé à
la théorie de la « panspermie dirigée », selon
laquelle l'origine de la vie sur Terre serait
due à une contamination extraterrestre délibérée.
Son argument est que l’ADN de l’être
humain — qu’il connaît bien — semble
être le résultat d’une évolution bien
plus longue que l’histoire d’Homo sapiens
sur la Terre (l’ADN aurait donc commencé
à évoluer ailleurs).
James Watson est un biologiste moléculaire
et généticien américain (il est toujours
vivant à l’heure où j’écris ce script,
en novembre 2022).
Il a suscité la controverse à la fin des
années 2000 en évoquant l’existence d’un
lien génétique entre l’intelligence et
la race.
Je vous raconte la découverte de la structure
de l’ADN dans la 7ème leçon du module.
Que retenir de Jane Goodall ?
Jane Goodall est une anthropologue britannique
(toujours vivante).
Elle est célèbre parce qu’elle est considérée
comme la plus grande experte au monde sur
les chimpanzés, qui sont les animaux les
plus proches des êtres humains (nous partageons
98 % de nos gènes).
Sur le plan scientifique, elle a analysé
les interactions familiales et sociales des
chimpanzés avec des études de terrain pendant
plus de 50 ans.
Son travail a été révolutionnaire dans
la mesure où il a montré que les chimpanzés
peuvent apprendre à fabriquer et à utiliser
des outils (alors qu’on croyait jusqu’alors
que c’est une propriété humaine).
Elle a également remis en cause la vision
idyllique des chimpanzés (liée à la croyance
selon laquelle la violence est propre à l’organisation
des sociétés humaines) en mettant en évidence
le fait que les chimpanzés peuvent être
très violents (par exemple, certains adultes
chassent et mangent des singes plus petits).
Sur le plan personnel, elle met son nom et
son influence au service de la protection
de l’environnement.
Elle a notamment fondé l'Institut Jane Goodall
pour la protection de la biodiversité, l'aide
au développement durable et l'éducation.
Que retenir d’Andrew Wiles ?
Andrew Wiles est moins connu que les trois
autres scientifiques que je viens de vous
présenter, mais je l’ai choisi parce qu’il
est un des mathématiciens les plus connus.
Britannique, prof à Oxford, il est entré
dans l’histoire de la science en démontrant
ce qu’on appelle le « grand théorème
de Fermat » en 1994 (Pierre de Fermat est
un mathématicien français de l’époque
de Descartes).
C’est un accomplissement exceptionnel parce
que cela faisait plus de 300 ans que personne
n’y était arrivé, au point que les mathématiciens
considéraient la démonstration comme impossible.
Wiles, lui, y parvient de manière originale.
Il démontre que le grand théorème de Fermat
est une conséquence d’un autre théorème
— en vertu de quoi il lui suffit de démontrer
l’autre théorème en question.
La première dimension intéressante de la
découverte est que Wiles travaille sur un
univers mathématique particulier (les propriétés
des courbes) pour prouver un théorème qui
concerne un autre univers mathématique (le
grand théorème de Fermat concerne la théorie
des nombres).
La seconde dimension intéressante est que
Wiles avance pendant 8 ans dans le plus grand
secret — ce n’est pas une partie de plaisir,
mais Wiles sait qu’il n’est pas rare,
dans l’histoire de la science, que plusieurs
scientifiques prétendent faire la même découverte
en même temps.
Il présente sa solution en 1993 ; ses pairs
trouvent quelques failles ; et il vient à
bout de ces failles en un peu plus d’un
an.
________________
Alors,
la vidéo vous a plu ?
J’espère que oui.
Je vous rappelle
que c’est un extrait
de ma formation de culture générale
« Culture Express ».
Si vous voulez en savoir plus,
cliquez sur le lien
qui apparaît maintenant
en haut à droite de la vidéo,
ou bien
sur celui qui est dans la description
de cette vidéo.
Voilà voilà,
comme d’habitude
n’hésitez pas à m’écrire
dans les commentaires,
et puis SURTOUT
N’OUBLIEZ PAS
que vous n’avez PAS BESOIN
de vous prendre la tête
pour vous cultiver.